so i do have to say that um
superstore coming onto streaming has
been a boon for right now
like we started watching like in my
household we started watching it again
from the very beginning
yeah and it's not that we didn't know it
was funny it was just like there are
certain things you forget
that you're like right yes i love that
moment i love that moment i love that
moment looking back now
on like god like you're in the sixth
season now
of the show what stands out to you as
like really great memories
of making this show with these people oh
i mean
it's it is a joy to go back and watch
some of the old episodes during the
pandemic
i i did actually go back and watch some
of the old ones kind of randomly
um and it was really fun to see the
things that you kind of forget about
because when you're filming it and
you're filming so many and there's so
many jokes
you forget about the little things you
forget about the little bits you forget
about like
what was going on with who at what point
that day
that kind of thing um so it was really
nice you know i think for me it's like
the stuff that we were doing off screen
as much of the stuff that we were doing
on screen you know like
we were we've been notorious for you
know
singing between takes there's a lot of
hamilton that's gone on a lot of drake
singing a lot of
you know just just fun and just like
hanging out you know that's the thing
that i always say that it's like i
always feel like i'm going to get to
hang out with my friends and we just
happen to make a tv show in the process
like that's really what it
genuinely has always felt like so yeah
it's always a joy to go back and watch
and like
like reminisce it's like a it's like a a
photo album that comes to life
really you have like a whole tv show
that's right that everybody in the world
gets to enjoy with you
yeah exactly it's a real gift
you know people often say that oh it's
like being with family it's like we are
a family we're a family and
certainly like working on it for six
seasons you have to get really close
with everybody
um but you know you said it's like going
in
and just hanging out with your friends
but if you could like elaborate
more for people to give them really an
idea of what it's like
to be this close with people and to
share this very unique experience with
with a small group of people yeah i mean
as an actor your job is to kind of well
first of all
often you go in and do lots of different
shows doing lots of different parts
you know it's it certainly is an up and
coming actor you're doing smaller parts
here and there so when you
become you know you get the opportunity
like becoming a cast member on this show
it's cool to just to kind of like sit
into it for a bit you're not just coming
in and being like i have to know my
lines i don't want to embarrass myself
i i gotta make sure that i like don't
step in front of the wrong person in the
craft service line you know
getting to just like treat it like it's
your nine to five like it's like this is
your job that you get to go and do every
day i think is a
real gift that i mean listen i worked as
an actor for many many years
and that's not necessarily something
that i experienced until
recently in my career in the past you
know like seven eight years
so that first of all is cool for us but
to give context
you know you're showing up to work at
six o'clock in the morning um
which means depending especially where
you live in la uh because there is
traffic that early
um you could be getting up at 4 30. so
and you could be you could be there
until six seven eight o'clock at night
so you're spending a
long long time with this group of people
which either can be awesome like it has
been for us because you
you happen to all click and the stars
kind of align
and everybody's really fun and cool or
it can be drudgery and that's the truth
so we we've been just like so lucky and
it's it's just
i think it's very rare and i think that
it was never lost on any of us
that you know we were brought together
randomly it's like they say you can't
choose your family but you can choose
your friends
well i think that that applies to this
because it's a work family we couldn't
we didn't choose each other we were all
kind of like
thrown together all of a sudden you're
in this high stress
situation you know also doing a tv show
certainly in the beginning you could get
canceled at any time you don't know when
this thing is going to go away there's
you know so
that affects different people in
different ways some people get
super insecure some people get overly
confident like
it can bring out the worst in people at
the best of times if that makes sense
and we just didn't really ever have any
of that we just
really had a great group of people from
the beginning and it was just a joy
every
every step of the way truly but six
seasons
is a real accomplishment it's like you
said you can
now we're seeing series that are done in
one season two seasons whatever
six seasons huge yeah what's the mix of
emotions for you
um you know knowing that it was coming
to a close
i mean it's first of all it is such an
accomplishment
it's not lost on me that it is very rare
to get a gig that lasts that long
as an actor in general certainly in the
landscape
of tv that we have now and streamers and
like you're saying shows that
last three seasons people think that's a
huge accomplishment so
that's awesome that's just awesome like
on every level but
it is sad because i think for the first
few years you are still
like we're gonna keep going are we gonna
get picked up again and then you know
you get into like season four or five
and you're like i think we're i think
we're doing this everybody like i think
that we're safe
so obviously you can't run forever no tv
show lasts forever unless you know your
grey's anatomy which i love and i hope
it does run forever
um but they all come to an end and i
think no matter when it was if it was
now if it was in a year if it was in
three years i think it's always going to
be
very emotional you know it's a loss like
it is it's a loss
to not only you know again mourn the
loss of getting to play
that character and getting to work with
those actors but also
a loss of your day-to-day life it's not
just the other actors we have a lot of
the same crew that we've had from the
beginning
you know maria who did my hair literally
from the pilot till now you know i see
her every day
you see these people more than you see
your loved ones so it's weird to then
one day just go
bye guess it's good for now you know
like it's a
it's an odd kind of phenomenon so it's
definitely emotional for sure
and you have to i think you really do
have to kind of like mourn it a little
bit
mm-hmm the series finale for a beloved
sitcom is a huge deal like people always
will remember how that series ended and
what the episode was like
without giving anything away you know
how do you feel people will react
to this one i wish i knew we haven't
shot it yet and i have not seen a script
yet
so i am i am as in the dark as everyone
else
in general we are the actors are the
last people to see
any of the scripts and even after we see
them they still go through
changes so uh in general it's tough to
kind of comment sometimes about when
when you get asked in interviews like
what's to come this season and it's like
i don't i don't know but right now i
truly don't know and i'm so excited to
find
out obviously yes you know there's a lot
of pressure i'm sure that they're
feeling too because
these characters have become so beloved
and our fan base has been like so
devoted and so lovely and also i i may
add
has exploded in the past month because
we've been put on netflix around the
world
basically in many places other than
america
and it's been doing so well that now
it's such an interesting phenomenon
because as the show is kind of coming to
an end and we're shooting the last few
episodes
we're getting all this crazy amount of
of
social media attention and love from
around the world for people who are just
finding it now
so so yeah i'm assuming there must be a
lot of
pressure that our writers are feeling um
to kind of
to to finish the story in a way that
feels like it honors
the characters that that we've all grown
to love over the past
year what's the sensation knowing now
that the love that the show was getting
like does it feel odd
because you like you described in the
very beginning you don't know if you're
gonna get a second season you don't know
there's a there's all that sort of
uncertainty even though you're confident
in the product
how does it feel now knowing that so
many years later you've got people that
are just so
attached to it i mean it's
i personally always felt very confident
about the show
in that when i read the pilot in pilot
season i was just like
how has this show never been made the
premise is super clear
the characters are super clear this is a
concept that is not hard to explain
i feel like sometimes tv shows if you're
having to explain the show
in more than like three or four
sentences perhaps it's gonna lose people
our show is just like it's the office in
a big box store and people go oh okay
like it's an
easy concept to understand uh and even
if you've never worked in one of those
stores
you've probably been in one of those
stores or have a concept of them so i
feel like it's just
i was just shocked that no one had made
this show before
and it's amazing you know and i i said
from the beginning i was like the show's
gonna get picked up it's gonna run for
seven seasons
i guess my number was a little off we
got six instead of seven
but um it's a it's awesome and the fact
that people are still finding it
and still like so excited by it and it's
it's a joy i mean it's a it's a gift
i'm so sorry my gardeners have shown up
early
please tell me if this sound is terrible
um and we can pause until he moves away
from the front door like why is that the
place
it's fine hey come in come on uh put on
your mask
uh no it's it's it's a joy to be on a
network show at the worst of times
but when you're on one that feels
creatively fulfilling
and is fun and it is a great group and
people really genuinely
seem to love it i mean that's the dream
there's truly to me there's just nothing
better
well has done a lot of great things over
the years one of them that i find really
unique about
comedy is how it was able to incorporate
things that are happening in real life
like things that are not funny but bring
them into
the show and you know either poke fun at
them
or sort of look at the bright side of
them or even really show
how much they affect the characters
but still keep things you know
superstore like how does it
feel to be able to say that you were in
a show that also addressed
you know the really substantial topics
of the day while also still making
what's going to be probably a comedy
classic
i mean to me that is that's the
the goal and the dream like i come from
a second city background where
you know we write our own shows and
there's a real kind of focus on
reflecting back to people what
what our current experience is in the
world in this kind of time
and so that's that's i mean i've written
a bunch of shows both in toronto and
chicago the second cities with that in
mind
so getting to be on a television show
that kind of embraced that same idea was
like first of all i was like oh my god
this is amazing i love this like this is
kind of like
my style of comedy and also for me it's
like
you know we're we're representing a
cross-section of of people
certainly in america but i think all
around the world like
these are people that we can relate to
and we know that they're kind of living
in the same world that we really live in
in real life so it would almost feel
disingenuous or weird to not comment on
the things that are happening in the
world and i think that
what the show has done really well over
the years is finding what that balance
is
you know the healthcare episode we did
is a great example of
you know addressing this thing and then
kind of pointing out that it's like
it's not a cut and dry issue it's not as
easy as as
some people think it may be to just kind
of like solve it um
you know and being able to also address
certain things in ways
where they don't offer we don't offer a
solution it's just pointing out that
it's like hey this is the world we live
in
isn't that wild that this is this is
going on in this world that we all live
in
um i think that that's really been smart
i think that it has really kind
of elevated the comedy because um it's
allowed people to see
their own experience reflected back to
them but in a way that has
either levity or also just allows them
to see
to see something you know that may have
experienced they may have experienced
personally reflected back to them i
think that
you know um i read once like the science
of comedy
someone said that laughter is
recognition we laugh because we want to
communicate that we understand a joke
so i think that that really speaks to
like a human's need
to want to be understood and see
something that resonates if that makes
sense yeah
and finally what have you loved about
working with america ferreira and how
does this show change
in her absence america is amazing you
know she obviously
came into this having so much experience
and and being such a
total pro in every way she's not only
an amazing actress but she's also been
she was an amazing producer she was a
great ally to have she's super smart
she really can kind of like look at a
script or an episode and kind of see
things that it's like well what about
this what if we changed this it needs
this
um so that was something that i really
learned a lot watching her
and then also she started directing on
our show as well uh a few seasons in and
so it was really cool to kind of get to
see her do that
and and she of course took to that
immediately which i think a lot of
actors you know they can kind of go down
that path as well i think the two things
kind of go hand in hand
um so it was great you know it was
awesome to get to see her and all those
kinds of different
jobs and thrive in all of them and then
you know it was
very sad to see her go obviously she was
there from the beginning and we were all
as i said a very tight-knit group of
tight family
um and so yeah it was it was really sad
but
uh it was also kind of interesting to
see
where the show went because you know i
really felt like as a show that has
always kind of represented
real life stories and very real people i
liked the opportunity
that we got to kind of address something
that would happen like that happens in
these stores
you form these bonds you work with these
people for years and years and years and
then
people move on people get other jobs
people move away
and what does that look like you know
and and so i think that that was kind of
like an interesting story opportunity to
get to see our characters and how they
dealt with that and i really loved
you know the moments that we got to have
with dina and amy um at the beginning of
the season
as amy was leaving and it really kind of
like that friendship
throughout the seasons i know of
everybody we all love jonah and amy i
love jonah and amy but for me
i think the real love story over a lot
of those seasons was the friendship
between
dina and amy and i think it was a really
cool thing to kind of
see that and see how that affected dina
and then see how that has kind of like
impacted her throughout the rest of
season six